There's lots of debate and there has been over
time about if and when and whether it's ever OK
to make an analogy to Hitler and to Nazis.
And the analogies often are not warranted. They
don't make sense. They're not well calibrated
to what we're looking at in the modern day.
However, on Fox News a few days ago, Judge Jeanine
Pirro went on a rant about Hispanic immigrants
that is almost identical to the language that
we saw from Nazis and other antisemite about
Jews in the past. Listen to what Judge Jeanine
Pirro had to say about being released today.
Now, who's got covid? Wait a minute. Do you
listen to me? They've got covid. They've got
all kinds of diseases. They are being released
into the United States. Now, you're not going
to tell me that a governor is going to shut
me down and not allow me to do my job and
let the illegals, because we've got a heart.
They have all sorts of diseases and they're
being released the way you would release an
animal into the wild. They're being released
into the United States. This is typical Third
Reich anti-Semitic rhetoric used to justify the
genocide of Jews during World War Two, replacing
Jews with Hispanic immigrants. In the story, it's
the same language. I'm not saying Judge Jeanine
is Hitler. I'm saying this language is the same
now. You can even actually go back beyond
World War two for this. If you go back to the
black plague in England, it was blamed on Jews by
antisemite there. The blaming Jews for disease is
a really old thing. But if you look at Third Reich
propaganda, specifically the justification for the
cleansing of the population was based on the idea
of an alien race of Jews poisoning the culture,
bringing disease. This exact type of thing
we're seeing from Judge Jeanine. Now, again,
as I mentioned last week, even this type of
rhetoric when you talk about coronavirus is
nonsense because the U.S. has a significantly
higher per capita case rate than Mexico.
There's no reason to think that covid is coming
from Mexico to the United States. We have way
more of it here. But ignore that for now. This
type of defiant sounding anger from Judge Jeanine
was the same type of thing applied to Jews during
Hitler's Germany. The dehumanization is present
in so many genocides. You look at the
Rwandan genocide as another example.
I recently read a very good book about the
Rwandan genocide by Philip Gourevitch. Excellent,
disturbing but excellent book. The Kernel of an
idea that started the genocide. And there's a lot
of colonial forces that that sort of were involved
in the creation of this idea. The idea was
that the Hutus and Tutsis were not only clearly
distinct ethnic groups, but one was subhuman,
one was dirty, one was unrefined and
unsophisticated, and the Hutus decided
that the Tutsis were inferior and they were off
to the races with the disgusting genocide. As I
mentioned in our segment about the Fox News focus
on the border last week and will again this week
during John Saki's hatzakis press briefings. This
is what they've found as their new punching bag.
Trump leaves and Biden comes in. The country has
given Joe Biden the highest initial approval for
a president in nearly 30 years. 70 percent
want covid relief, 80 percent agree with Joe
Biden's federal mask mandate for transportation
and federal offices. Vaccination has tripled
since Joe Biden took over. The world is moving on
from Trump, so they have cultural issues like Dr.
Seuss and suppose that council culture and now
they've fixated on the border, which shouldn't
surprise us because this has been their playbook
for a long time. Remember talking about a migrant
caravan leading up to the twenty eighteen midterms
the day after the twenty eighteen election? We
don't hear about a migrant caravan until October
of twenty twenty when they need that again.
And part of this is also strategic. Texas
and Mississippi are opening wide open,
even though health officials say it's too early
to do that. They're getting rid of mass mandates,
they're getting rid of everything. Ending
that right now is likely to cause a search.
And they are preemptively on the attack
against Hispanic immigrants to be able to blame
them when the surge hits in places like Texas.
Judge Jeanine obviously should be fired for this.
But is Fox News going to fire her when the
audience loves this stuff? Probably not. So
I would expect Judge Jeanine. Maybe she'll get a
promotion and a raise for this rant, which even
if you watch the video, she was alongside her,
although there even Giraldo looked perplexed
and sort of distraught to the extent that he's
able to during that absolutely outrageous rant